krankenhaus entlastungsgesetz und zum
infektionsschutzgesetz verabschiedet
dazu ein statement von entspannen und
danach hier so fragen der meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren wir haben
heute im kabinett mehrere gesetzentwürfe
verabschiedet mit denen wir unsere
wirtschaft unseren arbeitnehmern und
arbeitnehmern aber auch und gerade unser
gesundheitswesen in diesen schweren
zeiten unter die arme greifen und
unterstützen wollen und vor allem alle
beschäftigten im gesundheitswesen aus
vielen telefonaten begegnungen und
e-mails weiß ich was unsere ärztinnen
und ärzte unsere pflegekräfte und alle
die jeden tag im gesundheitswesen tätig
sind gerade leisten
sie organisieren ihren klinikbetrieb in
kürzester zeit neu sie improvisieren
machen überstunden arbeiten für zwei
oder auch für 3 sie kümmern sich um
schwerkranke und häufig auch um sehr
besorgt patientinnen und patienten in
bricht teilweise das einkommen weg
aufgrund all der maßnahmen die sehr
kurzfristig in den letzten zehn tagen
beschlossen worden sind und viele
begeben sich bei ihrem einsatz auch in
gefahr selbst angesteckt zu werden denn
ärztinnen und ärzte pflegekräfte
apotheker viele andere die können eben
keine heimarbeit machen in allen im
gesundheitswesen möchte ich sagen wir
brauchen sie wir sind dankbar für ihren
einsatz und wir tun alles damit sie gut
und sicher arbeiten können dazu auch
zwei gesetzte heute im bundeskabinett
zum einen wir spannen einen finanziellen
rettungsschirm für unsere krankenhäuser
auf der planbare operationen verschiebt
wer neue intensivbetten aufbaut für mehr
personal und mehr material braucht um
corona patienten zu versorgen bekommt
einen finanziellen ausgleich das ist
konkret eine tagespauschale von 560 euro
pro bett des frei geräumt wird und dem
nicht genutzt wird gerade auch für
planbare aufnahmen und operationen für
das neue intensiv bett mit
beatmungsgerät gibt es einen zuschuss
der krankenkassen von 50.000 euro und
die länder haben sich in einer
telefonkonferenz bereit erklärt auch
hierzu weitere in
die zions mittel zu geben für
zusätzliches material gibt es 50 euro
zuschlag pro patient der abgerechnet und
aufgenommen wird in den entsprechenden
finanzströme und für pflegekräfte im
krankenhaus steigern wir das was pro tag
gezahlt wird auf 185 euro ist eine
deutliche steigerung von 146 auf 185
euro und das ist wichtig es wird in
diesem jahr nicht spitz abgerechnet
anschließend das heißt also die häuser
können sicher mit dieser liquidität
gerade auch im rahmen des pflege budgets
mit dem geld für die pflegekräfte planen
und wer sogar darüber hinausgehende
kosten hat kann auch die geltend machen
zweitens gleichen wir mindereinnahmen
und mehraufwand der vertragsärzte aus
denn die ärztinnen und ärzte in den
niedergelassenen praxis den 170.000 in
deutschland sind der erste schutzwall
auch in unserem kampf gegen des corona
virus viele patientinnen und patienten
die nicht wegen corona ihren arzt
aufsuchen würden verschieben derzeit
ihre arztbesuche oder machen sie online
das führt dazu dass nicht wenige
arztpraxen in deutschland im moment
massive umsatzeinbrüche haben und
deswegen wollen wir sie wollen wir es
möglich machen dass die kassenärztlichen
vereinigungen auch dort eben
entsprechende unterstützung geben können
damit niemand übermäßige umsatzeinbrüche
jetzt für diese nächsten wochen und für
diese nächste zeit haben muss sondern
sich eben auch hier auf die
unterstützung verlassen kann
und diejenigen die korona patienten
behandeln oder auch ein mehraufwand
haben ja gerade entsteht aus der
behandlung werden natürlich entsprechend
vergütet was ich auch wichtig finde auch
als dankeschön an die kassenärztlichen
vereinigung ist dass wir die 11 6 11 7
das ist ja die 24 stunden
bereitschaftsdienst nummer der
kassenärztlichen vereinigungen dass wir
sie jetzt auch gesondert finanzieren es
ist massiv ausgebaut worden
die kapazität hinter dieser nummer es
gibt bis zu 4 500 1000 anrufe in der
woche über 11 6 11 7 im moment geleistet
werden das ist eine enorm große zahl
zeigt aber auch das große
informationsbedürfnis der bürgerinnen
und bürger
für den kassenärztlichen vereinigungen
sehr dankbar dass sie dort mit helfen
aber sie soll natürlich dann auch die
entsprechende finanzielle unterstützung
bekommen genauso wie explizit auch
finanzielle unterstützung für coop 19
ambulanzen sogenannte fiber ambulanzen
die er mittlerweile in vielen regionen
entstanden sind damit man eben nicht mit
kowitz verdacht und verdacht auf corona
infektionen in die arztpraxen in der
einzelnen geht sondern daneben gezielt
zu dieser kurve 19 ambulanz gehen kann
dass auch dort eine entsprechende
finanzierung sichergestellt ist drittens
schützen wir pflegeheimbewohner und
pflegekräfte vor infektionen entlasten
pflegeheime von bürokratie und gleichen
corona bedingte mehrausgaben aus dieses
programm hatte ich letzte woche hier
schon nach gesprächen mit den
pflegeverbänden und pflegekassen
vorgestellt und das was wir eben dort
miteinander vereinbart haben setzen wir
jetzt auch teilweise hier mit diesem
gesetz oben nämlich das was eben
gesetzlich zu regeln ist
viertens wir ändern das
infektionsschutzgesetz bündeln
kompetenzen und ermöglichen damit
schneller und effektiver auf bundesweite
epidemien zu reagieren
dazu soll in ausnahmefällen für einen
befristeten zeitraum der bund
zusätzliche kompetenzen erhalten
das gesundheitsministerium hat dann die
möglichkeit vorschriften für den
grenzüberschreitenden reiseverkehr zu
erlassen
etwa wenn im bahn- und busverkehr
meldepflichten eingeführt werden
wir haben dass die banken die
möglichkeit maßnahmen zur sicherstellung
der grundversorgung mit arzneimitteln
anzuordnen etwa wenn bestimmte
medikamente bevorratet werden müssen wir
stellen sicher und machen's möglich dass
überall verordnungen in einer zeit wie
dieser viele regeln auflagen
dokumentationspflichten die normalen
zeiten sinn machen in zeiten wie diesen
aber eben eher hinderlich sind um
flexibel reagieren zu können und auch
die große zahl von patientinnen und
patienten und von ratsuchenden
bürgerinnen und bürgern tatsächlich auch
angemessen zeit widmen zu können dass
wir sehr sehr kurzfristig durch eine
alpha ordnung aussetzen oder verändern
können das gleiche gilt übrigens auch
für vergütungsregelungen
es gibt aus den unterschiedlichsten
bereichen des gesundheitswesens die
berechtigte nachfrage danach jenseits
der krankenhäuser und niedergelassene
ärztinnen und ärzte
wie auch ihre vergütung in einer zeit
wie dieser so ausgestaltet sein kann
dass sie tatsächlich auch die chance mit
ihrem angebot ihrer praxis
wirtschaftlich zu überleben auch dort
das kann dann eben kurzfristig über eine
verordnung geregelt wenn um ein
konkretes beispiel zu bringen
die hebammen haben zu recht darauf
hingewiesen dass in zeiten wie diesen
ist sinn machen könnte und nicht nur
könnte wahrscheinlich sogar sehr sinn
macht ihr angebot auch online machen zu
können und telemedizinisch machen zu
können
neben etwa die geburtsvorbereitung und
die begleitung eine solche
abrechnungsmöglichkeit gibt es heute
noch nicht und eine solche könnte dann
eben in zukunft dann schnell geschaffen
werden um nur eines von vielen vielen
beispielen aus diesen tagen zu bringen
ich will darauf hinweisen dass das
infektionsschutzgesetz einen neuen
paragraphen erhält bis ende des jahres
der auch für diejenigen die wegen
kindergärten und schulschließungen auf
einkommen verzichten müssen nachrangig
zu kurzarbeitergeld und anderen
finanziellen ausgleich eine
lohnersatzleistung möglich macht darüber
hat es eine grundsätzliche vereinbarung
und einigung mit den ministerpräsidenten
der länder gestern gegeben dass es eine
solche regelung geben soll und wir haben
sie eben hier in das
infektionsschutzgesetz aufgenommen um
insbesondere auch für die eltern die ja
auch sich finanzielle sorgen machen und
fragen stellen
eine entsprechende unterstützung wie
gesagt nachrangig zu anderen leistungen
möglich zu machen und wir haben
aufgenommen in dieses gesetzeswerk zum
infektionsschutzgesetz eine regelung zum
erleichterten bau von krankenhäusern und
gesundheitseinrichtungen eine änderung
im baugesetzbuch das heißt dass
übergangsweise bis ende des jahres alles
das was zusätzlich gebaut wird auch
vorübergehend gebaut und eingerichtet
wird in deutlich leichteren und
beschleunigten baugenehmigungsverfahren
im gesundheitswesen jetzt auch umgesetzt
werden kann
fünfter und letzter und wichtiger punkt
wir haben in diesem gesetz
und dem gesetzespaket auch die bafög
regeln geändert
wer mit anpackt dann packt im kampf
gegen das virus dem wird seine
entlohnung die er dafür bekommt nicht
auf das bafög angerechnet der einsatz
der studentinnen und studenten muss
belohnt werden und nicht finanziell
bestraft aber auch diese kleine aber
feine regelung ist bestandteil des
gesetzes werk ist übrigens auch wichtig
nicht zuletzt für die vielen
medizinstudierenden die gerade mit
anpacken und bereit sind mitzuhelfen
insgesamt also ein ganzes bündel von
gesetzesänderungen aber die sind
notwendig um unser gesundheitssystem so
aufzustellen dass es die aktuellen
herausforderungen und diese ganz
besondere lage vor der die
bundesrepublik und unsere bürgerinnen
und bürger stehen gemeinsam bewältigen
kann
allerdings weiß ich auch dass er auch
ausdrücklich gesagt es wird trotzdem
schwierig so sehr wir uns auch bemühen
finanzielle verluste auszugleichen
bürokratie abzubauen verfahren zu
beschleunigen alle nachteile in jedem
einzelfall werden wir nicht kompensieren
alle hürden nicht abbauen können wir
werden jeden tag alles dafür tun ist so
gut als möglich zu machen und bei jedem
neu auftretenden problemen und da machen
ist die schnell verordnung jetzt auch
leichter bei jedem neu auftretenden
probleme auch zu reagieren aber zur
wahrheit gehört eben auch in jedem jeder
lage in jedem einzelfall wird das nicht
immer zumindest nicht immer sofort
gelingen diese epidemie bleibt eine
große herausforderung
wir bleiben dabei auf das angewiesen was
all diejenigen antreibt den
medizinischen berufen arbeiten ihren
willen zu helfen ihren unbedingten
einsatz ihr mitgefühl für die
patientinnen und patienten und dafür
sind wir allen die im gesundheitswesen
und in der pflege arbeiten jeden tag
aufs neue dankbar antwort aber auch in
tat für die gesetzesänderung ausdrücken
und möglich machen sollen und dafür wenn
ich das noch mal sagen darf zur
unterstützung derjenigen die im
gesundheitswesen arbeiten sollten
diejenigen die können in den nächsten
tagen zu hause bleiben denn das hilft
auch so kommen wir zu ihnen fragen ich
werde das immer
eins zu eins machen eine von ihren
fragen eine frage die mich hier erreicht
hat per e mail
kaczynski ist der erste warten sie bitte
aus micro er bilde waren gestern wurden
ja die maßnahmen noch mal verschärft mit
einer kontaktsperre und vor gut einer
woche am 14 märz haben sie folgende
erklärung abgegeben
ich zitiere achtung fake news es wird
behauptet dass die bundesregierung bald
massive weitere einschränkungen des
öffentlichen lebens ankündigen wird das
stimmt nicht was war die grundlage für
diese erklärung und was hat sich dann in
den zwei tagen bis zum darauffolgenden
montag verändert als bund und länder
eben genau diese massiven
einschränkungen geschlossen haben anlass
für diese meldung unsererseits war
ich weiß nicht ob es auch sie erreicht
hat weil viele journalistinnen und
journalisten wie viele kolleginnen im
politischen betrieb mich auch
angeschrieben haben das massiv ich frage
mich manchmal von welchen ressourcen
getrieben
in sozialen medien behauptet worden ist
dass es zu einem bestimmten zeitpunkt an
diesem tag eine pressekonferenz
unsererseits gäbe indem wir binnen
minuten sozusagen entsprechend alles
schließen würden und das hat zu
teilweise sehr panikartigen reaktionen
an verschiedenen stellen geführt und ich
finde es eben wichtig dass wenn solche
fake news und falschmeldungen
in dieser massivität das war nicht nur
eine wortmeldung wie es die immer gibt
sondern man hatte tatsächlich den
eindruck dass war mit finanziellem
hintergrund irgendwie getrieben auch in
den sozialen medien ist zumindest eine
vermutung beweisen kann ich es nicht
aber so massiv hab ich das jedenfalls in
18 jahren politik noch nicht erlebt wie
das an dem samstag war haben wir eben
darauf reagiert um das klarzustellen an
der stelle hätte man ein stück klarer
vielleicht auf diese konkrete meldung
hinweisen sollen
mit dem fsg wird eine regelung
geschaffen mit denen ärzte
zwangsverpflichtet werden können
warum ist das notwendig und welche ärzte
sind davon betroffen
in absprache mit den kolleginnen und
kollegen aus den ländern haben wir
vereinbart dass die zuständigkeit für
diese frage bei den ländern verbleiben
ich wollte einmal fragen sie hatten ja
es gab ja ein passus infektions in dem
neuen entwurf in der formulierungshilfe
zu der überwachung von standortdaten
warum haben wie diesen versuch abgeräumt
und was sind aus ihrer sicht
alternativen dazu wir haben aus dem auf
was wir aus anderen ländern lernen
können und auch aus einem land wie
südkorea als demokratischen rechtsstaat
ja gesehen dass die frage wer hat mit
wem kontakt gehabt aber auch wie sind
bestimmte bewegungsmuster in einer
region mithelfen kann ihm tatsächlich
infektionsgeschehen zu verlangsamen und
zu reduzieren und wir sind uns sehr sehr
einig auch innerhalb der bundesregierung
dass wenn mit blick auf die massiven
grundrechtseingriff die auch verbunden
sind mit den maßnahmen der letzten tage
wenn wir da auch ein weg wieder
gemeinsam herausfinden wollen und müssen
das dann weiterhin die frage wie können
wir kontakt nachverfolgung auch mit den
und ressourcen die dafür notwendig sind
tatsächlich weiterhin sicherstellen und
kontakt nachverfolgung das sagen uns
alle experten ist ein sehr sehr
wichtiges instrument also immer dann
wenn jemand positiv getestet ist auch
alle anderen mit denen er in den letzten
tagen kontakt gehabt hat zu informieren
und zu bitten oder gegebenenfalls auch
anzuordnen je nach dem in häuslicher
quarantäne zu gehen dass das ein sehr
sehr wichtiges instrument ist um die
verbreitung dieses virus zu verlangsamen
solange wegen kein impfstoff haben und
dazu ist eben das zeigen andere länder
auch ein entsprechendes instrumentarium
hilfreich gleichwohl und das ist die
vereinbarung macht das natürlich auch
sinn dass im gesamtkontext zu
diskutieren über die maßnahmen die
notwendig sind dass wir dann eben
schritt für schritt auch in eine
situation kommen
verweise auch maßnahmen wieder anpassen
zu können die getroffen worden sind das
thema ist also weiterhin thema für uns
in den gesprächen aber es muss natürlich
auch insgesamt eine große unterstützung
im politischen raum und im
gesellschaftlichen raum haben und es gab
sehr unterschiedliche rückmeldungen sehr
sehr unterstützende aber eben auch
einige die nach gefragt haben wie
konkret und warum das ausgestaltet wird
und ich finde bei einer solch
grundsätzlichen frage
und dazu haben wir uns dann entschieden
macht es sinn sie dann tatsächlich auch
länger als ist in dieser woche
parlamentarisch vorgesehen wäre aber zu
diskutieren
srk in einer app arbeitet womit leute
sich dann freiwillig freiwillig
eintragen können und so weiter ist das
jetzt der weg worauf sie setzen oder
eine freiwillige meldungen beteiligung
ist ja immer möglich auch nach heutiger
gesetzlicher grundlage also auf
freiwillige verfahren zu setzen
ich weiß dass das robert-koch-institut
wie übrigens auch andere an solchen
modellen und angeboten arbeiten
und das ist ja grundsätzlich aber erst
mal gut und hilfreich wie im übrigen ja
auch die anonyme nutzung von
bewegungsdaten die auch möglich ist
einfach nur zusehen sozusagen ist
insgesamt in der gesellschaft eine
bereitschaft da und kann man das auch
nachvollziehen den bewegungsdaten
weniger unterwegs zu sein als unbedingt
nötig und die bewegungsdaten scheinen
das zu zeigen das ist tatsächlich eine
reduzierung von sozialen kontakten und
mobilität gibt das sind aber alles dinge
die mit heutigem recht auch möglich sind
und angebote die dann auch entsprechend
entwickelt werden
an den reformen zum fsg gab es am
wochenende massive kritik seitens der
länder waren die gesetzentwürfe nicht
mit den ländern abgestimmt und rechnen
sie mit zustimmung des bundesrates
ehrlich gesagt habe ich mich aber
natürlich niemals so anwesende über
manche überschrift gewundert in den
letzten tagen weil es keine
kompetenzverschiebung gibt alle
kompetenzen und zuständigkeiten und das
ist auch mein ausdrücklicher wille der
länder und kommunen in fragen des
infektionsschutzgesetzes bleiben ja
vollständig erhalten und werden noch
nicht irgendwie relativiert also die
frage geben der maßnahmen die in den
letzten zwei wochen angeordnet worden
sind ob bezogen auf einzelne bereiche
oder eben auf ganze bundesländer sind
kompetenz der länder und kommunen und
sollen es auch bleiben
worum es hier geht ist dass da wo auch
nationale fragen betroffen sind wie etwa
die einreise nach deutschland das die
frage welche gesundheits nachweise und
welche informations nachweise und
kontakt nachweise sind für jemand der
nach deutschland einreist zu geben eine
aufgabe ist die der bund regeln sollte
darüber gab es immer konsens zwischen
den bundesländern
dem bund die frage dass es wenn es eine
grundlage gibt wieder gerade eben
gestellte ortung dass das eine
bundesgesetzliche regelung braucht auch
dort gibt es keine keine debatte und die
frage dass es für veränderungen durch
verordnung im arzneimittelrecht in
fragen der ärztlichen der krankenhaus
der apotheker vergütung oder auch der
rahmenbedingungen der rechtlichen
grundlagen etwa in der anwendung von
arzneimitteln bundeseinheitliche
ausnahmeregelungen braucht auch darüber
gibt es im grundsatz und auch im
konkreten des gesetzentwurfes im übrigen
keinen keinen dissenz ich habe gestern
abend mit den gesundheitsministern der
bundesländer intensiv über den
gesetzentwurf gesprochen und er hat
grundsätzlich eine sehr hohe zustimmung
zwei fragen die eine ist ein bisschen
spießig tut mir leid werden wird bezahlt
das alles besonders wer zahlt
vorhaltekosten für betten die dann
eventuell von niemandem belegt sind
mit dem kleinen appendix wird hier die
pkv auch beteiligt oder landet das
allein bei der gkv oder kommt das
steuerzuschuss dazu zweite frage können
sie ein bisschen konkretisieren wie der
schutzschirm für die niedergelassenen
ärzte aussehen soll und wer den konkret
ausgestaltet
das ist keine einzige frage sondern eine
sehr berechtigte natürlich ist hier um
viel geld geht
der schutzschirm den wir für die
krankenhäuser aufspannen wird je nachdem
wie es sich entwickelt bis zu zehn
milliarden euro zusätzlich kosten
deswegen finde ich auch in der debatte
darüber was jetzt angemessen ist und was
nicht schon den hinweis wichtig das ist
hier um große zusätzliche finanzielle
größenordnung geht auch richtigerweise
geht
wir haben die kliniken um eine große
aufgabe gebeten und wir brauchen sie
auch für eine große aufgabe denn wenn
eben die zahl der intensiv und
beatmungspatienten möglicherweise wenn
wir die entwicklung in anderen ländern
sehen steigt dann ist das nur gemeinsam
zu schaffen mit denjenigen die im
krankenhaus ärztinnen und ärzte
pflegekräfte viele andere tätig sind und
übrigens auch mit einer vorausschauenden
planung
das kann man nicht und das zeigt die
erfahrung aus anderen ländern
plötzlich innerhalb von stunden
umstellen sondern man ist dann im
vorteil und das ist der zeitliche
vorteil den wir in der bundesrepublik
haben weil wir sehr früh siehe webasto
ja schon unsere sensorik und auch unsere
testverfahren ausgerichtet haben auf das
was rundum corona in deutschland
passiert eben die gelegenheit haben sehr
früh das gesundheitssystem und auch das
krankenhaus system sozusagen um zu
switchen umzusteuern
auf diese mögliche große herausforderung
mit corona patienten damit das aber eben
auch mit finanzieller sicherheit
verbunden ist gibt es jetzt auch
erstmalig für leere betten weil es die
ausdrückliche wunsch ja ist leere betten
im moment zu haben für den fall der
fälle mit 560 euro pro tag eine gar
nicht so geringe vergütung wenn man
schaut was ansonsten im schnitt für
fallpauschalen pro tag wenn man das mal
umrechnet gezahlt würde diese pauschale
wird aus dem bundeshaushalt finanziert
die weiteren maßnahmen die ich gerade
dargestellt habe die 50 euro zuschlag
pro patient für corona schutzausrüstung
pauschal die 185 euro pflege zuschlag
wie auch die investitionszuschüsse
werden von den krankenkassen
beziehungsweise teilweise aus der
liquiditätsreserve des gesundheitsfonds
finanziert wir haben zudem auch
vereinbart und in den gesetzentwurf
geschrieben dass wir uns bis mitte des
jahres also bis ende juni spätestens
zusammen auch mit praktikern aus den
krankenhäusern aus dem gesundheitswesen
einfach anschauen
für die maßnahmen wirken wenn wir
feststellen sie sind nicht ausreichend
oder nicht zielgenau genug dann steuern
wir natürlich sehr sehr schnell nach
mein grundsätzliches versprechen an die
krankenhäuser dass wir alles dafür tun
werden dass sie nicht einen
wirtschaftlichen schaden erleiden
dadurch dass sie uns helfen in dieser
schwierigen lage
dieses grundsätzliche versprechen gilt
es gab eine debatte über das wochenende
darüber was das richtige instrument ist
dieses versprechen umzusetzen
und mir war wichtig dass wir ein
instrument finden das auch funktioniert
sicher funktioniert weil das eingeübt
ist in den abrechnungs wegen und in den
in den mechanismen die wir machen aber
das versprechen bleibt erhalten und
deswegen werden wir uns sehr genau
anschauen wie sich das entwickelt und
gegebenenfalls nachsteuern
die private krankenversicherung ist wie
sie ansonsten auch bei
krankenhausfinanzierung und das war
einer der gründe übrigens warum wir uns
für diesen weg entschieden haben
natürlich auch in all diesen fragen wie
etwa bei den fallpauschalen und den
zuschlägen entsprechend beteiligt es
gibt mehrere fragen seien die
niedergelassenen ärzte da geht es vor
allem auch darum dass wir mehr als zehn
prozent umsatzeinbruch hat das dann eben
innerhalb der kassenärztlichen
vereinigung und des volumens das ja
vereinbart ist mit den krankenkassen
auch entsprechend entsprechend
umgeschichtet werden kann wenn sich dort
abzeichnet dass es auch dort nach
verhandlungsbedarf gibt dann sind wir
auch dank des infektionsschutzgesetzes
wenn es so kommt zügig in der lage
nachzusteuern mehrere fragen ihr per e
mail zur medizinischen schutzausrüstung
wann kommt die an wie werden pflegeheime
versorgt ein weiterer aspekt also wie
ist der stand bei der versorgung mit
medizinischer shooters wir haben im
grunde eine kontinuierliche auslieferung
von schutzausrüstung auch heute morgen
sind an welches richtig im kopf hab alle
17 karten und an die bundesländer
lieferung erfolgt sind manchmal kleiner
und manchmal größere mengen weil wir
eben nicht warten bis wir eine ganz
große menge haben nach tagen die zu
laufen sondern immer sofort versuchen
tag gleich alles was da ist auch zu
verteilen
die verteilung an die krankenhäuser die
pflegeeinrichtungen den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst und andere beteiligte
machen die länder auch das ist im
föderalen miteinander richtig weil wir
hier aus dem bundesministerium heraus
gar nicht in der lage wären muss man
auch mal objektiv sagen sachgerecht
zuzuordnen welches krankenhaus jetzt in
welcher region den dringendsten bedarf
auch hat wir gehen gar noch mal durch
ein tiefes tal das weiß ich aus den
beschreibungen aus den praxen aus den
krankenhäusern aus dem öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst was die versorgung mit
schutzausrüstungen angeht wir sehen
gleichzeitig aber auch dass seitdem
china exportbeschränkungen aufgehoben
hat und wieder in großem umfang
produziert
zumindest signale auch der entspannung
gibt das zeigt sich schon am preis der
gefordert wird der sich deutlich
reduziert hat im vergleich zu letzter
woche aber noch lange nicht da ist wo er
mal doch immer auch noch mal war
wir wollen aber natürlich weiterhin auch
mit europäischen partnern
und zwar nicht erst irgendwann sondern
in dieser frage auch bald schauen ob und
in welchem umfang auf produktionen
wieder in europa und in deutschland
möglich ist
frau ludwig die frage der verpflichtung
von ärzten ländersache ist aber trotzdem
viel bitten noch einmal zu erläutern wie
denn diese regelung gedacht dass also
ärzte und pfleger die im augen die aus
dem beruf ausgestiegen würde und in
einem anderen beruf arbeiten sollen
möglicherweise von einem bundesland
herangezogen werden und dann in ein
krankenhaus bestellt werden es geht ihr
darum eine gesetzliche grundlage erstens
gibt es schon viele gesetzliche
grundlagen das infektionsschutzgesetz
das merken ja viele dieser tage
beinhaltet deutlich mehr und deutlich
umfängliche regelungen und
eingriffsmöglichkeiten als man
vielleicht in den letzten jahren und
jahrzehnten manchmal so wahrgenommen hat
aber es geht ja darum in einer absoluten
notlage in der wir momentan in
deutschland nicht sind stand heute in
einer absoluten notlage natürlich auch
entsprechend versorgung sicherstellen zu
können
ein solches instrument wäre ein vorrats
instrument sowohl für die länder wie für
den bund im fall der fälle sicherlich
keines das man in einer lage wird diese
anwenden würde ich bin vielmehr sehr
froh und dankbar dafür dass viele
ärztinnen und ärzte teilweise auch
pflegekräfte und andere die im ruhestand
schon sind sich entschieden haben jetzt
wieder zurückzukommen mit anzupacken wir
mögen das heute im kabinett auch
gesetzentwürfe beschlossen die die
anrechnungsregelungen
mit renten und anderen attraktiver
gestalten so dass es sich auch lohnt
bafög habe ich gerade schon genannt
zusätzlich zu arbeiten sowohl für
diejenigen die schon im ruhestand sind
für auch für diejenigen die im studium
sind und wenn ich die initiativen sehe
die es von ganz vielen auch stücken
medizinstudierenden gibt wie aber auch
von ärzten und pflegekräften im
ruhestand oder beim medizinischen dienst
für ärzte und pflegekräfte die beim
medizinischen dienst beschäftigt sind
von sich aus sehr aktiv sagen ich will
mithelfen in dieser zeit tatsächlich
auch vor ort in den einrichtungen dann
finde ich ist das ein starkes zeichen
unseres gesundheitswesens und aller die
in diesen berufen tätig sind
nochmals zur ausrüstung ausstattung
corona tests gibt es engpässe da das ist
die eine frage und die zweite frage ob
wir uns an südkorea ein beispiel nehmen
sollten konsequent zu testen und mit
hygienemaßnahmen versuchen sollten das
virus einzudämmen
einer unserer großen vorteile das
bestätigen alle experten ist dass wir
schon immer in anführungszeichen sehr
umfangreiche test kapazitäten in
deutschland hatten sich über die letzten
jahre sehr große laborkapazitäten auch
in der niedergelassenen ärztlichen
versorgung entwickelt haben das ist im
vergleich zu anderen ländern
insofern vorteil als in vielen ländern
manchmal nur ein oder zwei institutionen
im land manchmal nur die in unikliniken
überhaupt testen konnten über wochen
teilweise bis heute das wäre so als wenn
ich für ganz deutschland nur das
robert-koch-institut oder nur drei
unikliniken tests durchführen könnten
das würde offenkundig zu einem
eklatanten engpass führen und wir haben
ein echtes in echten mehrwert und dann
lernt man ja deutsches gesundheitswesen
ich jedenfalls jeden tag noch einmal
ganz neu schätzen bei allen problemen
die es auch im alltag gibt einen echten
mehrwert dadurch dass wir so große
laborkapazitäten haben wir haben
kapazitäten von bis zu 200 tests in der
woche 2000 tests in der woche schon
heute in deutschland ich erlebe viele ob
in der pharmaindustrie in der
veterinärmedizin viele andere die labore
haben die durch eine einfache umstellung
auch in der lage wären die
entsprechenden tests durchzuführen dass
es auch dort eine große bereitschaft
gibt damit
zu machen engpässe entstehen im moment
ein anderer stelle nicht in der test
kapazität sondern in der frage der
reagenzien und des zubehörs
und zwar nicht weil wir jetzt so viel
mehr testen sondern weil der ganze rest
der welt jetzt auch viel umfänglicher
anfängt zu testen
und manche der hersteller jetzt mit der
produktion wenn auf einmal die ganze
welt das ist wie mit den masken wenn auf
einmal die ganze welt beginnt dinge viel
stärker nachzufragen als vorher müssen
eben sehr viel schneller auch
produktions kapazitäten angepasst werden
aber wie gesagt wir schaffen bis heute
einen sehr sehr hohen eine sehr sehr
hohe test zahl in der woche was ich aber
erlebe aus rückmeldungen die ich aus dem
alltag bekomme aber auch mit dem wie die
entwicklung in der letzten wochen
gewesen ist und der frage in welchem
stadium wir jetzt sind dass wir unter
den vielen gesprächen mit dem
robert-koch-institut und mit anderen
dass wir nochmal genauer schauen müssen
wer wird in welcher lage warum
eigentlich idealer weise getestet weil
wir schon unsere test kapazitäten halt
tatsächlich auf die bereiche
konzentrieren müssen wo es tatsächlich
auch ein mehrwert bringt es ist ja jetzt
schon die regel dass ein arzt
entscheiden soll darüber ob ein test
notwendig ist oder nicht und ich
verstehe übrigens jeden bürger der aus
einer unsicherheit heraus sagt ich
möchte gern getestet werden das ist ja
ein zutiefst nachvollziehbares empfinden
zu wissen was ist bei begrenzten
kapazitäten müssen wir aber halt schon
auch miteinander schauen wo es
tatsächlich sinnvoll ist und angezeigt
ist
und das wollen wir eben noch mal in
dieser lage die ja mittlerweile eine
andere ist als noch vor drei oder fünf
wochen noch mal mit den experten
entsprechend anpassen ich war geht von
heute hast du mich würde mal
interessieren wie denn die zahl der
intensiv kapazitäten jetzt eigentlich
sind die soll ja verdoppelt werden wo
stehen wir da zweitens ist es ja wohl so
dass in baden württemberg eine zentrale
quarantäne einrichtung geschaffen werden
soll des bundes
vom drk was hat es damit auf sich und
drittens fehlt noch einschätzungen zu
denen sage ich mal die zarten
optimistischen äusserungen vom rk ii
heute intensiv kapazitäten nach dem was
die gesundheitsminister der länder das
ist ja da bin ich auch sehr dankbar für
zuvörderst dem föderalen miteinander
ich bin sehr dankbar dafür mit welchem
einsatz das betrieben wird für ein
miteinander zu fördern ist eine
landesaufgabe auch in der
krankenhausstruktur das jetzt zu
begleiten dass es in jedem land sehr
intensive planungen gibt die intensiv
kapazitäten massiv zu erhöhen in vielen
bundesländern auch sie tatsächlich schon
in einem ersten schritt zu verdoppeln
und das dort mit den krankenhäusern sehr
intensiv daran gearbeitet wird es gibt
ja auch seitens der intensivmediziner
des fachverbandes mittlerweile online
tools mit denen nachvollzogen werden
kann auch das angebot das in den
jeweiligen kliniken da ist nachdem was
eben am letzten freitag wir haben
nachher um 16 uhr eine erneute
telefonkonferenz aus den ländern
berichtet wurde arbeiten alle intensiv
und zuversichtlich daran die kapazitäten
zu verdoppeln
ein thema ist natürlich die zahl der
beatmungsgeräte da ist der weltmarkt
auch so dass gerade viele kaufen das
sind bin ich sehr froh dass es uns sehr
frühzeitig gelungen ist da ja auch in
größerem umfang zu kaufen
aber jetzt müssen sie natürlich und sie
werden jetzt sozusagen woche für woche
zu laufen und nicht alle auf einmal weil
sie ja auch gebaut werden werden müssen
übrigens ein thema ist ja nicht nur die
infrastruktur bei intensiv sondern auch
das pflegepersonal
ich erlebe dass sehr viele kliniken und
sehr viele länder konzepte entwickeln
wie man eben in schnell schulungen jetzt
zumindest für den fall der fälle auch
personal darauf vorbereiten kann das
sonst nicht in der intensiv arbeitet
zumindest einige wichtige
grundzüge eben für einen möglichen
einsatz in einer lage in der
intensivmedizin tatsächlich in einer
schulung vermittelt zu bekommen auch
dort gibt es gute konzepte mittlerweile
in vielen häusern dem auch genutzt
werden
wir haben im übrigen auch das
robert-koch-institut nochmal die
empfehlungen zum umgang mit
medizinischen personal gerade jetzt
übers wochenende arbeit überarbeitet ist
auch auf der seite des robert koch
instituts zu finden
die frage war ja immer was für probleme
wir kommen wenn wegen quarantäne
maßnahmen möglicherweise viele erste für
die pflegekräfte eines krankenhauses
dann über zwei wochen nicht verfügbar
sind
dass es dort eben für diejenigen die
nicht positiv getestet sind aber für
eigentlich in quarantäne wären aber für
den medizinischen betrieb gebraucht
werden dass wir viel passgenauer und
detaillierter auch ein angebot für die
kliniken haben durch das robert koch
institut entwickelt wie sie dann in
einer solchen lage eben die balance
schaffen zwischen ich muss die
medizinischen betrieb aufrechterhalten
und gleichzeitig wie schütze ich die
patienten aber auch die mitarbeiter vor
infektionen auch das ist wichtig weil
die beste kapazität an betten bringt im
krankenhaus nichts wenn kein personal
und dann auch entsprechend da ist dass
der bund zentrale quarantäne
einrichtungen geplant wäre mir jetzt
neue des bundesministerium für
gesundheit tut es jedenfalls nicht
vielleicht ist das noch eine eine
begebenheit aus der zeit vor
aschermittwoch weil bis aschermittwoch
wir ja die bis dahin eben richtige
politik der vermeidung des eindringens
nach deutschland gebracht haben das
waren die zentralen unterbringung der
rückkehr aus haan in germersheim in
kirchheim teck und in köpenick wo es ja
noch darum gehen dass diejenigen die
zurück kehren zentral unterzubringen
sind und wie es darüber geschafft haben
über wochen den eintrag nach deutschland
zu vermeiden
dafür hat es mal suche geben nach
weiteren möglichen zentralen quarantäne
unterbringung für den fall dass man
weitere rückkehrer hat da wir aber seit
norditalien und aschermittwoch eine neue
lage in deutschland und europa haben
machen solche zentralen quarantäne
unterbringung
jedenfalls aus bundes- sicht keinen sinn
und deswegen kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen dass der bund
aktuell jedenfalls wir nicht
entsprechende einrichtungen untersucht
oder sucht was das robert-koch-institut
angeht ist das ja ein hinweis von herrn
professor wähler den ja aus der
entwicklung der zahlen genommen hatte
bei dir ja auch mit der nötigen vorsicht
gemacht hat das hat er ja sehr klar auch
eingeordnet das ist so scheint dass man
das aber eben noch nicht jetzt sicher
sagen könnte und ich finde es wichtig
dass wir transparenz sind auch unsere
behörden unserer robert-koch-institut
wir hier als bundesministerium
transparenz sind mit den erkenntnissen
die da sind aber sie immer auch
einordnen
in der frage wie sicher fundiert man sie
jetzt eben zu diesem zeitpunkt machen
kann und das hat der professor wieder an
dieser stelle gemacht ich fand es
übrigens auch wichtig dass das
robert-koch-institut jetzt erstmalig
auch die zahl der gelesenen hat
verleiten können das ist ja am ende auch
eine frage eben von annahmen und
herleitung unter dem vorsichtsprinzip
natürlich im rahmen einer solchen
wissenschaftlichen herangehensweise aber
ich finde dass eben auch wichtig dass
wir darauf schauen wo sind die
schwersten und auch die tödlichen
verläufen das aber eben auch der andere
teil dargestellt wird um die dinge
entsprechend einordnen zu können
programm lisa braun presseagentur
gesundheit herr minister sie haben an
dem gesetzentwurf noch gearbeitet am
wochenende zugunsten der krankenhäuser
können sie sagen was sie genau noch
zugunsten der häuser verbessert haben
und dann habe ich noch eine frage was
das was die reaktion der krankenhäuser
an geht es ja schon sehr sehr heftig die
landeskrankenhausgesellschaft hier in
berlin hat gesagt wir tun alles aber die
politik lenkt lässt uns hängen und zwar
haben die das heute noch gesagt und
nicht letzte woche wie sortieren sie
dass einen die wollen im grunde das
liquiditäts versprechen was der
aok-bundesverband neulich abgegeben hat
und das sehen die eigentlich jetzt mit
dem gesetzentwurf nicht erfüllt können
sie dazu noch sagen
also zum ersten wir haben ja sehr
umfänglich die
pauschalen zum beispiel erhöht wie sie
ja sicherlich beim leichten vergleich
des ursprünglichen gesetzentwurfes und
bis heute beschlossenen sehen können von
teilweise 410 oder 450 euro für kleinere
kliniken auf 560 euro pro tag das ist
hochgerechnet auf das was ansonsten wie
gesagt umsatzerlös pro tag pro bett ist
durchaus keine kleine summe dass der
pflege zuschlag nicht mehr spitz
abgerechnet wird sondern für dieses jahr
185 euro pauschal pro tag pro patient
ist eine enorme finanzielle sicherheit
für die für die kliniken die 50 euro
zuschlag für corona schutzausrüstung
auch das klingt pro tag pro patient erst
mal vielleicht im ersten mal nach
kleinen summen sind aber bei 22
millionen krankenhausfällen jedenfalls
einem normalen jahr in deutschland schon
enorme summen und unterschiede um die es
geht ich habe ja gerade gesagt bis zu
zehn milliarden euro und bei
gesamtausgaben von 80 milliarden euro
die wir im jahr für krankenhäuser haben
110 milliarden euro zusätzlich wie ich
finde jedenfalls keine kleine summe
gleichwohl verstehe ich ja das ist eben
auch nachfragen gibt und das ist
christus her miteinander im dialog und
im gespräch auch kontrolle kritik gibt
ich bevorzuge im zweifel konstruktive
kritik aber das ist jetzt alles wie es
ist
wir sind miteinander in einer sehr
stressigen situation und diejenigen die
es vor ort in den kliniken machen müssen
umsetzen ob in der geschäftsführung die
ärzte und pflegekräfte
da kann ich auch verstehen wenn dann
manchmal klare ansagen kommen kann ich
jedenfalls mit umgehen wichtig finde ich
dass wir einander zuhören und wir haben
zugehört und deswegen innerhalb von 24
stunden unseren gesetzentwurf in
reaktion auf kritik überarbeitet um eben
weitere zusätzliche sicherheit für die
krankenhäuser zu geben
ich will eins nur sagen für die experten
unter ihnen was krankenhausfinanzierung
und detail an geht der vorschlag den es
gegeben hat
man solle doch einfach ein zwölftel des
vorjahres budgets überweisen
und dann wäre sicherheit da hätte gerade
für die krankenhäuser die besonders
intensiv gefordert sein werden
nächsten wochen intensiv patienten
beatmungspatienten hohem aufwand eben
keine sicherheit gebracht sondern geld
das fehlt
wir hätten ganz neue abrechnungs wege
aufbauen müssen weil es den mechanismus
den sich einige da erdacht haben so noch
gar nicht gibt wahrscheinlich das
aufbauen der neuen abrechnungs wege und
der verrechnung zwischen den
krankenkassen wochenlange kraft gekostet
und deswegen haben wir uns am ende
entschieden wege zu wählen
für die finanzströme es ist sehr
detailliert krankenhausfinanzierung ich
weiß aber am ende auf besetzte verfahren
zu setzen und über die schnell viel
liquidität zu geben damit nicht auch
noch unsicherheit darüber entsteht wie
das denn abgewickelt wird so das war die
grundsatzentscheidung die zu treffen war
und dann gab es wie gesagt
hinweise und kritik und ich finde
wichtig dass man und dass wir dann auch
in der lage sind zügig darauf zu
reagieren die meldungen die ich jetzt
aus den krankenhäusern bekomme ist
durchaus so dass viele sagen das ist
jetzt erstmal auch okay damit können wir
arbeiten aber bitte ersparen lassen sie
uns nach einer zeit 12 monaten hinsetzen
und gucken wie die auswirkungen
tatsächlich sind auf die liquidität und
das ist was was ich fest zu sagen kann
wir werden uns das zeitnah anschauen und
wenn bedarf ist nach steuern mit blick
auf die uhr die letzte frage von frau
wer hat sonst noch eine letzte davon
christian feld hardy hauptstudio eine
frage noch mal zum gesamtvolumen sie
haben eben die zehn milliarden für den
krankenhaus schirm erwähnt lässt sich
beziffern was dieses gesamtpaket was sie
heute im kabinett beschlossen was das
kosten alles was im kabinett beschlossen
worden ist
im großen und ganzen sind es gut 10
milliarden euro im bereich der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung haben wir
vor allem jetzt erstmal auch den
mechanismus von umverteilungs
möglichkeiten innerhalb der geplanten
budgets und vor allem sicherheit dass
die auch tatsächlich fließen
der an der stelle und bei den
pflegeeinrichtungen kann man das volumen
abschließend noch nicht sagen weil eben
nicht ja klar ist sozusagen welche
betten oder welche tätigkeiten nicht
gemacht werden können wegen der
aktuellen wegen der aktuellen lage zur
wahrheit wird aber auch herz schon
gerade darauf hingewiesen es gibt auch
andere bereiche die zu recht sagen wir
haben aber auch finanzielle themen
heilmittelerbringer physiotherapeuten
die natürlich im moment auch deutlich
weniger patienten behandeln entweder
weil die patienten nicht kommen oder
weil es probleme gibt auch in der
schutzausrüstung oder anderes mehr
und ich möchte einfach dass wir jetzt
auch zeitnah wirklich bereich für
bereich schauen was ist das richtige
instrument damit umzugehen denn es gibt
ja auch die hilfen kurzarbeitergeld
liquiditätshilfen die im
bundesministerium der finanzen im
bundesarbeitsministerium in vielen
anderen bereichen gerade heute mit dem
kabinett beschlossen worden sind weil
wir uns natürlich schon was wirkt jetzt
auch für wen wie und wo gibt es
besonderheiten im gesundheitswesen die
wir dann eben auch entsprechend mit
abfedern müssen aber ich kann ihnen
versichern ich nehme das thema das kenne
ich auch allen die es betrifft
versichern sehr sehr ernst durch
entscheidungen der politik durch
notwendige entscheidungen der politik in
dieser lage wegen dieses virus und zum
schutz der bevölkerung sind binnen tagen
für viele in deutschland die
betriebswirtschaftlich verantwortlich
sind für ein unternehmen
gesundheitswesen die eigene praxis haben
die eine klinik betreiben aber auch für
viele andere ob es in der gastronomie
ist ob es hotels es ist erstmal ein
stück was zusammengebrochen sicherheit
weg sind mieten zu zahlen gehälter zu
zahlen und das alles innerhalb von
wenigen tagen und ohne irgendwie eine
vorankündigung und deswegen weiß ich wie
viel unsicherheit und befühlt 2
öffnung dabei fehlen ist im moment und
ich möchte gerne mithelfen dass wir
dafür fehlende perspektive geben können
einfach durch diese schwere zeit aber es
muss eine perspektive sein die auch
sozusagen zielgerichtet ist auf den
jeweiligen bereich und wir haben das
jetzt zügig deswegen für die
krankenhäuser getan weil wir bei denen
ja noch zusätzlich auch eine erwartung
formuliert haben seitens der politik
nämlich dass sie gerade aktiv alles um
steuern auch auf mögliche zusätzliche
intensiv von beratungskapazitäten und
dafür braucht es eben auch eine
finanzielle sicherheit
aber mir schon auch wichtig an alle
anderen die im gesundheitswesen tätig
sind dass ich persönlich aber auch wir
hier ministerium im blick haben was da
gerade passiert und was das für viele
viele hunderttausende die im
gesundheitswesen tätig sind gerade
bedeutet was da passiert vielen dank
dankeschön